[Applaudissements]
la course des champions le nouveau jeu
d'aventurés de france 2 animé par teddy
riner a commencé samedi soir sur france
2 bienvenue dans la course de champion
un démarrage timide pour la
superproduction du service public avec
seulement 1,6 million de téléspectateurs
le concept s'était dit renner qui nous
l'expliquent de toute la france aucune
raison affronté de véritables champions
au stade le pr
l'émission a bénéficié d'une mise en
scène impressionnante de moyens
colossaux mais aussi d'une promotion
ultra innovante
france 2 a recréé le parcours de
l'émission à l'intérieur du célèbre jeu
vidéo fortnight qui a séduit plus de 250
millions de personnes depuis son
lancement le 8 gamer confirmés ont pu
s'affronter sur twitch la plus grosse
plateforme de streaming devant plus de
200 mille personnes pour un total de 70
mille heures de visionnage une belle
promotion pour le show qui ainsi pu
limiter la casse lors de sa première
semaine samedi dernier prêche vous
l'aurez compris du courage du
dépassement de choix il va en falloir
dans la course des champions du
dépassement de soi c'est exactement ce
que france 2 a fait en cassant les codes
de la promo et en s'invitant dans le
monde des jeux vidéo pour séduire un
public plus jeune un effort récompensé
avec 11% de part de marché sur les
jeunes soit deux points de plus que la
case habituellement alors selon vous le
jeu sorte night est il sauvé la course
des champions 1 sur les cibles jeunes
11% sais pas non plus énorme
oui 11% et la moyenne d'âge de cette
émission est de 47 ans donc légèrement
plus jeune que danse avec les stars
alors que à l'époque c'était 60 ans
environ sur le samedi soir pour vous
france télévisions est contente du raid
du résultat sur cible évidemment ils
sont très contents avoir pas au niveau
donc diffusé samedi la prochaine
émission iris garde les deux prochaines
pour le mois de janvier à mon avis il se
gardait de prochaine emilie que vous
dites oui nous vient l'inquiétait pas
très content selon nos informations
c'est el hiri nairas il a trouvé ça
tellement mauvais qu'il n'a pas voulu
faire la promo et attend c'est vrai
qu'on appelait on n'a pas beaucoup vu et
on apprendra par sur la sur le sur la
5ème conférence est les dix premières
minutes il est parti mais la vidéo soit
du temps n'est pas content parce que
c'est pas les missions qu'on lui avait
vendu et surtout ils ont perdu tout le
monde à vouloir toucher les jeunes
ils ont eu quelques-uns mais ils ont
perdu tout le public entre guillemets un
peu plus âgée qui avait l'habitude de
regarder ça alors moi je veux tous les
tableaux cata sauf que dd pour le coup a
fait le job
nous aurons d'autres sportifs sur
d'autres chaînes qui sont oui qui sont
en fait malawi moi j'ai pas l'impression
d'être âgées
mais quand j'ai vu cette émission est
forte c'est tout moi je comprends bien
tu m'as perdu je trouve ça hyper
excluant qui périssent qu alors le
concept est simple il ya un mec qui part
avec deux minutes d'avancé un champion
qui lui courent derrière si moi j'adore
non il s'agit mais fortnight tout cet
univers et tous deux jeux vidéo moi tu
me perds complètement autant je trouve
que faire moyens mais parce que vous
étiez dit que c'est pâques aux côtés du
hasard le petit sursaut qui a eu chez
les jeunes comme maxime chance la
dernière fois qu'elle a touché un
clavier c'était le minitel rose c'était
pour l'heure dans son monde mais par
contre là c'est un flop total
et je trouve que ça se voit ce que tu
dis qu'il est pas vraiment intéressés
par le programme qu'il en train d'animer
parce que c'est une catastrophe on voit
ton bde riner il est quatre ou cinq fois
champion du monde
vous n'avez fait qu'une bouchée des
finances jean michel à peu près des gens
qui jouent à fornet qui n'étaient pas
devant la télé et pas sur france 2 moi
je vais trouver dynamiques et les plus
sympathiques investi franchement alors
c'est bien un truc à sauver dans
programme c'est plutôt lui